hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday May 27th 2019 what's going on
how I am on the road and I forgot my
[ __ ] recorder so I had to go out and
go buy a new one I can't figure this one
out I bought the olympus LS 100 and you
can plug a microphone into the bottom of
it but I'll be god damned if I can
figure out how to use it so they'll
probably be a lot of extra noise here
I'm trying to avoid it I should probably
set the thing down I don't know I'm just
using it like a microphone so I hope
this doesn't sound too bad anyway I am
here in New York City here for the
summer
I got an acting gig out here you know
I've been saying up and growing a
playoff beer but I'm not I got to have a
[ __ ] you know I got to have a
mustache for this role you know
unfortunately they're not gonna [ __ ]
glue one on so I've been growing one and
I just didn't want to walk around with
just the moustache you know what I mean
I figured if I had the full beard it's
the NHL playoff time and then also you
know if you just saw me with the
moustache all the time then you sell me
on screen you'd be like oh that's just
that douche from the podcast but if you
never really saw me with just the
moustache walking around as myself when
you go see the movie you'll be like well
who is this guy who is this person that
has piqued my interest I'm just [ __ ]
with you
anyways tonight Game one of the Stanley
Cup final not the Stanley Cup Finals
it's the NBA Finals but it's the Stanley
Cup final it's only one of them that's
what they tell me there's only one NBA
Finals but that's still called the
finals I don't know who the [ __ ] knows
all I know is it's going down tonight
and place where I'm staying the cable is
not working so I have to go out to a bar
to try and watch this thing I just don't
feel like anybody's going to give a [ __ ]
here so maybe I'll be able to get the
game on and got to go out to a bar even
though Oh [ __ ]
bili red fuzz-face has not had a drink
and six months I'm on the other side six
months in two days this more sand in the
bottom of the glass the hourglass and in
the top I'm running downhill now I'm in
New York City right now if I didn't
mention I forget if I did or not but
this is a hard city to not drinking and
last night I decided I was just going to
do a bunch of sets right so I started
off at the comic strip you know that was
the first Club that passed me way back
in the day when I moved here in 1995 and
then I was going to go to Dangerfield's
and then New York Comedy Club and then
down to the cellar that was the deal so
I went down and I did the the comic
strip and the stage is now against a
different wall which I never knew that's
where the original stage was I had no
idea
and when Seinfeld made his special he
asked if they would put the stage back
there like absolutely so that was kind
of cool because he's a bunch of old
photos in that Club of like Eddie Murphy
on drums while Joe Piscopo is on like
the microphone or whatever and at least
guys from back then and I used to always
think that I was standing on the same
stage as them and I wasn't but and I'm
still not but at least I'm in the same
area so I thought that that was pretty
cool
and let's see then I went and I had a
good set didn't have a great set but
tried out this new [ __ ] then I went to
Dangerfield's and that did not go well
at all didn't go well at all and I had
the classic you know white girl and her
[ __ ] twenties or whatever just hating
all my abortion material even though I
said that I was I was pro-choice I
didn't understand it said she got mad
and and I wasn't a good mood and the
whole [ __ ] thing escalated and then
she [ __ ] stormed out which isn't what
I want to have happen so I was so bummed
out that it went that bad
at Dangerfield's cuz I just [ __ ]
bombed right that was it the friend of
mine and they were like where do you
want to go next I was it's like you know
if I don't give a [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
sick of everybody making you know this
person was literally in the crowd going
to switch subjects switch subjects
nobody here cares nobody wants to hear
this so it's just like why are you
acting like you're speaking for the
whole crowd granted nobody was laughing
but like you know shut up you didn't
hire me okay this isn't a private show
and you're paying me and you told me
what the [ __ ] I couldn't couldn't talk
about you decided to go to come I'm
telling you man if you're really a super
sensitive person don't go to comedy
shows that that's what they have
musicals for they turned beetlejuice
into a musical right there was Mamma Mia
for a while there was cat's meow right
go see that [ __ ] you won't be offended
why didn't they use real cats why are
people dressed like cats where cats
dressed like people I was triggered so
my friend talked me and uh come on keep
going so then I went on the New York
Comic Club this is what's crazy about
stannum I do the exact same material in
[ __ ] murder murder and then last then
I went down to the that I feel good
about myself again and then I ended up
at the Comedy Cellar and I did end up
doing a spot down there and you know and
then and it went I had a good set their
best set was probably at the New York
Comedy Club but I'm just gonna keep
working this [ __ ] while I'm here it's
kind of cool I get to do like this
acting gig out here and also put
together my new hour and it's looking
like my new special is going to be
coming out sometime I don't know if I
had to guess I'd say late summer but I
have not gotten any official word from
[Music]
Netflix
I haven't got any word yet so that's
basically what I've been doing my cigar
smoking is off the rails alright as far
as like you know my drinking I got that
totally under [ __ ] control and so my
thing that you know you just replace a
vise with the vise which is a hard
[ __ ] thing so I mean I must have fun
that European trip Iceland all the way
through to Tel Aviv and the rest of the
month I mean I probably smoked fifteen
cigars this [ __ ] month it's
disgusting
so I'm laying off of those things now so
now I'm off those I don't drink I don't
watch porn anymore I'm not [ __ ]
smoking cigars I'm not totally laying
off cigars but I'm just I'm taking it
easy for the rest of the month here
we're gonna regroup
you know I'll smoke one on my birthday
or something like that I don't know what
but I don't know it's just like such a
once you [ __ ] that Pandora's box
segment once you [ __ ] do [ __ ] like
that it's really hard to like go back to
being like you know it's so [ __ ] up
it's like when you were a kid you what
you were you were a straightedge
look I didn't really start going out
drinking drinking I mean I had a few
sips of a beer here or there maybe snuck
one out of my dad's stash in the fridge
astros I believe he used to drink back
in the day but like the first time like
I went out drinking with you know
underage kids you know in high school I
was like 17 so basically for the first
17 years of my life I was stoned sober
straightedge no cigars no booze no pot
cookie
none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was fine
and then all of a sudden you have a few
drinks you're like oh this feeling this
is [ __ ] great as you're doing damage
to yourself so then the thing the hard
[ __ ] thing is it's easy to be a
straightedge if you never [ __ ] did
anything but once you do [ __ ] to then go
back to that you know I have you know I
like to think I have really good
willpower but man it is [ __ ] hard
because now I think like alright well
I'm not drinking so I gotta get I got to
get some sort of uh a buzz something you
know so then I just start smoking too
many [ __ ] cigars and then I'm
drinking soda because I like having soda
with the [ __ ] cigars with you know
the sugar with the [ __ ] smoke you
know and then all of a sudden I that
drinks you know I stopped drinking but
now I drink [ __ ] root beers like
they're going out of style and [ __ ]
I'm smoking cigars it's like what am i
doing so you know now I have to go back
to being [ __ ] Billy boredom here old
bored Billy the pasty [ __ ] because I got
this [ __ ] movie and I got up I got to
stay in shape you know all these [ __ ]
actresses out there [ __ ] moaning and
complete [ __ ] art everybody there's
business you got to watch your [ __ ]
weight so now that's it I got [ __ ]
green beans and beets and [ __ ] what
else did I get in there I got one other
[ __ ]
little box of no excitement and the
fridge hummus broccoli lean turkey
patties I mean it's just like it's just
it's the food equivalent to how funny
this podcast has been so far now bill
why would you [ __ ] on yourself
anyway but the game one starts tonight
I'm gonna go find a bar where I can go
watch this thing and I got to tell you
man
I don't like how much people are
confident about the Bruins I don't think
that people are given the Blues their
respect I think the people on TV are
doing enough that they're trying to sell
the series so people will sit down and
watch it but these [ __ ] st. Louis
blows or a problem I am not taking them
lightly whatsoever they are big they are
fast and they don't look [ __ ]
intimidated or anything that just
[ __ ] mowing people down so I think
it's gonna be a very tough series it's a
friend of mine who really knows sports
tried to claim Bruins and six and that
made me feel good because he's usually
right but I am I don't know I'm oddly
nervous like I'm playing you know I
don't even play pick-up hockey anymore
I'm so [ __ ] busy why am i nervous
about this hockey game oh because they
represent the city that I grew up
outside of and this means something to
me you know so I'll be watching that
thing tonight we'll see I don't know
much about the Blues I know everybody on
their first line I just was when I was
watching when they played San Jose it's
just I don't know it seems like the West
is bigger and stronger to me but we
shall see but we have the core veteran
group that is already one one
Marshawn Bergeron Chara and Cray G and I
think that really helps our team and
gives us an advantage and I'm hoping
that uh I'm hoping we [ __ ] win the
thing all right
[Music]
congratulations to Lewis Hamilton when
in the the f1 there in [ __ ] Monaco I
didn't see a second of that because my
[ __ ] cable is out but I don't know he
won the pole position so I figured
alright well that's gonna be a boring
race and then I heard it was exciting
because this via nurses tires to the end
but there's no way to pass on that track
I don't know what I miss and [ __ ]
everything but Friday night when I first
came here a good friend of mine from way
back in the day I used to do shows with
him all the time
Talon had his show you know I was just
looking up to see what comics I still
knew and where the [ __ ] they were and so
I took took the train uptown to go see
him at Caroline's I used to open for him
all the time back in the day and we just
had a great time and he [ __ ] ended up
putting me on his show and dude I opened
up with the Michael Jackson bit in front
of an all-black crowd and I'll tell you
I can't remember the last time I lost a
crowd like that jeez I mean it was so
[ __ ] silent in there the joke became
how stunned I was that I lost them and
then I ended up killing again by talking
about how bad I was doing and they
really did not want to hear my take on
that documentary so at that point then I
was bombing so bad I was like [ __ ] it
then I did my Michelle Obama bit and at
that point they would just laugh it
because it was so [ __ ] ridiculous you
know at that point that you know me
going up there with my [ __ ] you know
white supremacist [ __ ] look with the
haircut you know would then would then
go into that and but talent was laughing
selves a good time but I used to do all
it shows that Sunday night at the Boston
to this day is still the greatest
[ __ ] comedy show I ever was a part of
and I'll tell you when you went up there
and the crowd was into you and you
[ __ ] killed I said this before like
you walked out of there wondering why
you weren't famous yet and then other
times when it didn't go well
you was the exact opposite you felt like
what the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] did I ever
ever even begin to think that I could be
in this business how dare I call myself
a [ __ ] comedian you know so anyway so
that I thought that that was gonna be
the worst [ __ ] thing but that [ __ ]
woman walking out crying two times in my
career I've made I've made somebody cry
in the audience and both times were a
Dangerfield's how crazy is that
I remember like 18 years ago I made this
woman cry and afterwards it went down
the cellar and I was talking to somebody
about it and somebody was saying I would
have been like [ __ ] you [ __ ] these are
the jokes I was like now now now I felt
bad about it you know I don't mind
annoying somebody but I don't want
somebody walking out crying granted the
first time the woman should have cried
alright the second time last night that
was just you know I would just say
that's just the fallout of people being
on social media I can I talk to you
regular [ __ ] Joe Sixpack [ __ ] about
your [ __ ] social media activity I got
to tell you for as much [ __ ] as they
give celebrities all right I feel like
your guy's behavior not all of you but
the worst of the worst you guys are
starting to act like like you know when
they say an actor is difficult to work
with that's the way like I don't know I
don't think that the average person
performer or just regular Joe can handle
that level of [ __ ] attention and
everybody giving him likes and thumbs up
and saying that they're [ __ ] heroes
and [ __ ] like that and and the [ __ ]
behavior of some of these [ __ ] people
you know enough change subjects move on
to the next one she was saying it like
she was like I was on Game of Thrones
and she was one of the [ __ ] eye and
watch that show why am i using that as a
[ __ ] reference by the way happy
Veterans Day to all the veterans out
there you know and I think it's great
that they have a day for you and I also
think it's great that feminists haven't
somehow figured out a way to take over
your day by saying well wait where
worriers to why aren't people
celebrating us do you know Fallujah is
one thing but to have the courage to
take your thumbs out and send a tweet
that you know might not get a hundred
percent likes and what that will do to
your self-esteem I know Bill you'd be an
extra kunti today I am I am extra kunti
I'm here alone in New York and I'm
missing my family but they're going to
be out here soon and everything's going
to be good my daughter is doing the
cutest
thing like we got this little puzzle
right and it has all the letters in the
Apple alphabet capital and lowercase so
she knows a lot of the letters now but
any letter she doesn't know she calls it
a B social has she'll pick up an F and
she'd be like B frog and also be like no
F frog she goes F frog and then she just
looks in the sincerest voice ever just
looks at me and she'd be like I like
frogs like I like frogs too buddy
right and then should be like you know
be kite I'm like no it's K kite she goes
K kite
then she look at me again and be like I
like kites and I'm like I like them too
buddy it's so [ __ ] cute I can't stand
it I can't stand it this that's
unbelieving can't believe I waited so
long to be a dip and I'm telling you
like I went on with her a little Lily my
heart is like at peace one of the few
things that ever happens just sitting
there like I could literally sit here
and do this with her all [ __ ] day but
unfortunately she's two-and-a-half years
old so she gets over things quickly and
then wants to go run and go do something
else so I took a walk through Central
Park yesterday so you know I'm trying to
you know because I've been eating a
little bit of pizza here trying to be a
you know good with the [ __ ] eating
bad and [ __ ] but us I figured I had a
couple of slices last night I should go
for a walk so I walked all the way up
like 30 [ __ ] blocks all the way up to
Central Park and I was thinking like
should I rent a bike and ride all the
way around I'm like I don't want to
[ __ ] then they're gonna ask me for an
ID and then I got to put the stupid
[ __ ] helmet on and I'm like I'm not
[ __ ] doing that so I just decided to
walk through the park and my god it
brought back so much [ __ ] with so
many memories I lived here for so long I
remember I had memories of comedians I
don't even know where they are anymore
we went rollerblading there in like the
90s
a bunch of different girlfriends he just
you know you always would go for a walk
in the park or whatever you know I used
to jog around what they now call the
Jackie Onassis reservoir thing there and
I got like three-quarters of the way
through the park and I realized that I
was near my old neighborhood I used to
live on the Upper East Side
I lived on 97th between 3rd and Lex and
I went back to that old neighborhood
holy [ __ ] when I lived there
this is comedian Dan Neiderman was doing
a joke that 96th Street is the last
Street a white person can legally live
on in Manhattan which was true and I was
living on 97th Street I lived there with
Bobby Kelly too and then we would walk
up to like a hundred Street that's where
our dry cleaner was and there was just a
bodega on the corner there was a grocery
store on 96th and Lex on the southwest
side and I'll never forget they this
[ __ ] guy used to mop the floor had a
dirty mop and it would just smell like
dirty mop water right after he mopped it
was actually worse if you got there
right after he mopped the floor she's
thinking why won't this guy just pour
some [ __ ] bleach in there and soak
them up it smelled so [ __ ] bad and
this is back before like there wasn't
there was no change in in New York City
as far as like you know cratenbarrel
Bed Bath and Beyond the gap all there
was nothing they had a Macy's I'm sorry
they had a few places like a Macy's
there was a Filene's basement there was
like the Wiz there was Modell sports but
pretty much everything else was like an
individually owned thing and when you
got up to where I was at like it was
considered so like no-man's land they
were I had to walk ten blocks just to
get to an ATM the ATM was republic bank
down on 86th and Third Avenue
I'd walk all the way down there Platt
past the movie theater that's still
there it was a pizzeria
uno down there was a long [ __ ] time
ago so I went back to the name
and it has changed first of all there
was so many [ __ ] stores that have
gone out of business because of Amazon
and I mean it's just how it is you know
I guess times change so the
brick-and-mortar stores are going unless
you're like a restaurant a liquor store
I don't know a bar or a major chain it
just seems like they're all going away
but I go to my my old block where I tell
you there wasn't [ __ ] there was this
little hole-in-the-wall Chinese food
place - number one listen to my god I
forgot about that
no but what's your order when you call
up let me get a chicken abroad check
they were always [ __ ] screaming like
they'd like the walk or something was
sizzling right into the phone this guy
would always [ __ ] least - call him up
you call up and you what you would hold
the phone away from your ear man those
were fun times and the [ __ ] food was
delicious so anyways I went back there
and now there's like a CVS on the on one
corner there's a [ __ ] that was an
empty lot - if I remember correctly
there's a CVS there with a building
above it there's a Taco Bell now they're
just insane [ __ ] that you never would
have seen I hated living up there
because there was there not there was
nothing up there I wasn't on an Express
stop there was no bank
there was no good places to [ __ ]
other than number one no but why what's
y'all got the grocery store they had a
dirty mop and it was just like it was a
[ __ ] walkthrough bedroom I actually
took a picture of the building and [ __ ]
I saw a poster because it gets too
[ __ ] weird people knowing that much
you know I've already told you the block
I was on but when I lived there like I
crossed the street was like a that place
was just a I don't know it was just like
your section open [ __ ] had a fence
around it now there's a giant building
there with underground parking these to
be crackheads underneath my stoop and
[ __ ] I come home at night man
it was so [ __ ] creepy you know when
someone's in that level of addiction
that underneath stares and when they
[ __ ] look up at you man it's like
you're in the Thriller video man I
remember I used to always have my
[ __ ] key out when I would turn the
corner and there'd be [ __ ] rats and
crackheads and all of this [ __ ] I went
up there and it was just like I I
couldn't I couldn't believe it how much
it's changed not granted I mean I lived
there 24 years ago so I was kind of
doing the math on that I'd be like if I
lived there in 1995 when I first came
there if somebody came up who had lived
there in 1971 and that really [ __ ]
with me was just like wow I am that
[ __ ] old Jesus Christ
that'd kill me what's-his-face David
Crosby they're doing a [ __ ]
documentary on that guy and he's 77
years old I could see 68 69 70 I had no
idea he was that [ __ ] old so anyway I
just kind of I just walked around the
Upper East Side and when I lived there
another time I lived on 79th in York and
there was no subway on the east side
other than the 6:00 train and that was
all the way on 77th and Lexington so you
had to walk I had to walk up to York
these are city blocks too not just
regular blocks so these are like long
walks up to York then over the first
over the second over the third over the
lexo York first second third Lex so like
four and a half city blocks and then I
had to go down to regular blocks it was
such a [ __ ] pain in the ass and it
was either freezing cold out raining or
[ __ ] like ridiculous humidity and I
was just sitting there going why does
the west side have like five different
subway lines and we only got one here
and I started reading about this [ __ ] I
made a little video about it but I guess
in the 1950s I think is when they first
tried to start it or I don't know what
by the way I remember it is in the 1970s
they were gonna make a second Avenue
subway it was going to go from the Upper
East Side all the way down to
Wall Street all right and people were
immediately upset by that because it
seemed like it was just for rich [ __ ]
white people on the Upper East Side who
wanted to their own private subway so
they started calling it the snob way and
this was sort of like the taxi driver
era of New York City so they were
bankrupt could have got a building here
for like but nothing and they just
didn't have any money but they had
started the project they'd started
building I think like three or four of
these stations so they stopped the
project but they completed the stations
and then they just I don't know what
they did they just walled them off or
whatever put a chain around the door and
there was all of these rumors with
everybody on the Upper East Side that
you know there was people living down
there like some escape from New York
[ __ ] or that they were gonna you know
assume that they were gonna start the
project up again which I think they did
right around the time I left there like
15 years ago long story short I actually
rode the thing for the first time they
didn't do what they were supposed to do
the thing was supposed to go straight
down the east side and it didn't at this
point it's like it's like three stott
it's like 86 73rd and something else and
then it cuts through Central Park and
goes right down the middle like on the
end our line so well I thought that that
was my there's any of this interesting
to you is this thing still recording I
can't even tell here oh the screen went
blank sorry alright Jesus that was 27
[ __ ] minutes Oh Billy [ __ ] Oh
Wendy here alright let's read a little
bit of the advertising here for this
week
[Music]
here we go I apologize if I'm not that
funny this week - time for the first
time in years I'm fighting off a mild
[ __ ] depression you know I don't know
I don't know what it is I haven't had
this in a [ __ ] while there's
something about coming to New York just
[ __ ] depresses me because so many of
my friends are dead gone or whatever and
you know I don't know I'm just you know
you know yeah it's one of the worst
things is when you find that when you
finally understand that ho you can never
go home you know even when you go home
because people have just left
everything's different they knock [ __ ]
down and stuff like that I don't know I
probably should have taken that [ __ ]
walk around the Upper East Side maybe
that's what the [ __ ] it was so anyways I
get myself out of this I worked out
today that's always good for for the
[ __ ] a depression here so I got a
couple of comedians I want to hype their
stuff here
Steve Simone one of the great people
I've met in this business such a
big-hearted guy has a new comedy album
out called Java that's available now on
iTunes and speaking of back in the day
an old school friend from back in the
day Maya DiGiorgio who I first saw at
the Boston Comedy Club way back in the
day which had the greatest roast most
talented [ __ ] comics there's no way
to describe the vibe of that Club it was
so exciting and so [ __ ] terrifying at
the same time it was back when New York
was in New York that I remembered people
selling drugs outside and I mean it was
it's not the [ __ ] Maybury that this
city has become for better or for worse
I mean it's better you know if you can
afford to live here but like all those
people they pushed out I don't know
about that and I'm not just talking drug
dealers obviously I'm talking about like
just working-class people that all got
pushed out of here so my ode to Giorgio
I used to work with her at the Boston
comedy club she has a one-person show
that is running in Soho it's the theater
that launched the Vagina Monologues they
picked up the show reading the copy here
the one that took a lifetime to write
she says my show incog-negro runs May
28th to June 2nd
and may 28th to tune first at 8:30 and
June 2nd at 4:00 p.m. the tickets are
$20 it's getting amazing reviews is one
person show
let's see here I have the algae's I'll
just post the the theater link let me
try to say that you didn't think if I
can actually get this thing to open here
[Music]
let's see where the hell is it
incog-negro is here summer sublet series
does it say the name of the [ __ ]
theater I don't know whatever I'll post
it in the goddamn tweet but definitely
go see her she's absolutely hilarious
but is like most one-person shows like
they they need to they have to sell a
certain amount of tickets so she can
continue doing it so definitely check it
out May 28th through June 1st at 8:30 in
June 2nd at 4th 4 p.m. my DiGiorgio and
incog-negro alright let's read some of
the advertising here oh honey could you
let's talk about something we can all
agree on saving money the reality is if
you're not shopping around you're
probably not saving money so what if
there was a way for somebody to do
something do some of the shopping around
for you well that's exactly what honey
does honey is a free tool that you
download to your computer browser while
you shop online huh scans the Internet
why honey for coupon codes and other
discounts then it automatically applies
the coupon with the biggest savings to
your cart that checkout like magic it
works on over 220 thousand sites like
Amazon Nordstrom j.crew Nike Best Buy
Target Macy's and more and it takes zero
effort to install just two clicks and
you're ready to start saving any time
you shop online instead of taking my
word for it listen to what actual users
have to say about honey look there's no
reason not to use honey it's free it's
free to use and easy to install on your
computer and computer just two ticks
click sorry don't take it from me take
it from our listeners get honey for free
and join
honey calm / / that's honey calm / / oh
honey the smart shopping assistant that
saves you time and money
alright the next one here LegalZoom ah
geez their legal zone running a small
business is a lot of work it takes time
and it takes money and you want all the
time of money you have to go towards
growing your business but what happens
when legal hurdles pop up along the way
well I'll tell you god dammit LegalZoom
is there to help nearly 2 million
Americans have used Legal Zoom to stat
their business with LLC's and
corporations and more but even after
your business is set up Legal Zoom can
still help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws and
contract reviews are all part of running
your own business and these are
precisely the kinds of cost hurdles that
can take time away from growing your
business that's why Legal Zoom created
their business legal plan get advice for
running your business from vetted
independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states
the best part is you want to get charged
by the hour since Legal Zoom isn't a law
firm make your time and money work for
you check out Legal Zoom business legal
plan at Legal Zoom calm now and get
special savings when you enter BRR at
check out Legal Zoom where life meets
legal legalzoom.com alright there we go
so Oh Billy yoga face I've been doing
yoga for the last couple of days I don't
know I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing both of my shoulders are [ __ ] up
now it's nice to know it's not rotator
cuff it's just like tendonitis so I got
to give him a break while I somehow I
have to try to get in shape for this or
stay in shape for this [ __ ] movie so
I don't know I'm trying I'm going for
walks I'm doing the elliptical I gotta
wear a knee brace now am i [ __ ] left
me cuz that thing has tendonitis it's
just like what the [ __ ] happened to me I
have a bet with Paul virzi that I'm
gonna be able to do 10 pull-ups when I'm
70 I called him the other day - already
given the money I'm like through this
but it's a [ __ ] wrap
but it's a rap it's over that's when you
know you're [ __ ] old you know what I
mean when you have like injuries like a
professional athlete has and [ __ ] and
you just got it from I don't know
walking from one couch to another
carpeted area alright let me let me do
some of the reads here for this week
jeopardy losers yo Billy smartass I'm
sure you've heard about this dude who's
making a run on Jeopardy
I haven't apparently he spent a year
preparing and if you watch the show at
all you know that he starts with all the
high-value answers first and by the time
they get to double jeopardy no one else
has a chance I love this guy I love this
guy
I want to start watching when they get
to final jeopardy he always knows he's
going to win because he has 10 to 15
times the purse everyone else has so he
bets really big because either way he
gets to come back tomorrow anyway and
then he put the S anyways check out this
clip of sore losers complaining because
they lost oh my god oh I loved every
second of this what are they complaining
about because he's too smart let's let's
have a listen here what's going on here
I hope what God's sakes come on told me
about what it's like to face off against
the man who seemingly cannot be stopped
all right Adam Levin joins us now along
with Alex look at these [ __ ] nerds
also lost the whole tower you guys are
the members of a very very interesting
Club one club that keeps on getting
bigger and bigger as this guy just keeps
rolling on Jeopardy Adam I want to start
with you because you got this guy
sitting in his library with a bunch of
books behind I mean you see a lot of the
games beforehand sometimes you get to
see who's winning before you take the
stage and you had a chance to see how
good he was was it intimidating
it was certainly something I had never
seen before in terms of his speed and
his strategy of using the bottom clues
to build up a big lead was I intimidated
maybe a little bit but I knew I was a
pretty good player and that I was going
to go out there what am i won this is
like ESPN for [ __ ] nerds I want to
see this there's one person here that
just looks like they're gonna be pissed
really looks like they're gonna be
pissed this is the one I want that's
what he told me to just focus on in
practice first this is a game this is a
fun experience and when it comes to
dealing with him and it was not what do
you mean it wasn't fun no secret of the
fact that James and I did not get on
backstage I did not feel he was
respectful to me he wasn't respectful to
some a lot of the other people to the
staff
oh god that's that is not a good look
back for the game yeah it just it wasn't
it wasn't what we were expecting yeah
you expected the win and you found out
that you didn't prepare enough so now
you I he wasn't nice to me to not to be
nice to you Jesus Christ you know it's
such a [ __ ] up world that we're living
in now that I won't be surprised if they
actually make that guy apologize for not
being nice and for winning and all of
this [ __ ] you know unbelievable look he
like didn't go to this job for like a
year well Milly you should have done
that the guy raised the bar he became a
professional jeopardy person what did
you do you did the New York Times
crossword puzzle every day and you
thought you were ready well guess what
he outworked you
and you got your ass whipped by a
goddamn nerd that's what she needs she
needs got John Goodman to revive as his
character the coach there from Revenge
of the Nerds well I thought the other
two they actually from the clips I
watched didn't seem like they would that
upset but good for that guy to know that
he's actually out there irritating
people makes me want to sit down and
watch it even more so thank you for the
heads-up all right reality show
opportunity dear Billy I love the 80s
two questions did you ever send in a
tape to be on the real world in the 90s
no I did not he said I know a lot of
wannabe actors started sending in tapes
when they realized you could get famous
off it would you rather be on Survivor
yes it's it's still on the air I know
it's still on the air because my wife
has watched every season or The
Bachelorette
the one where you're lumped in with 20
other losers to win over some chick if
winning meant your life depended on e
meant life depended on it thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself I have too many issues
with women to even think that I would
even remotely do well on Bachelorette
survivor me on an island with my pasty
skin you know what I yeah I wouldn't I'm
not a good-looking guy either I just
don't I just don't see myself as a 50 51
year old bald redheaded male being the
one that this woman's gonna pick you
know what I mean I I don't see that so I
say younger man I might have taken a
chance on Bachelorette but I'd have to
go survivor and I would need a sponsor
from some sort of sunblock company and I
need to rehab my shoulders because if I
can't physically win a challenge if I
have to rely on my brain I would lose so
I think I think I would die as is no
matter what either one so if I'm gonna
die then I would rather be on The
Bachelorette you know where I'm I can
actually eat real food and I've got to
eat maggots and try to stab [ __ ]
starfish with a stick you know talking
to a soccer ball I don't want to [ __ ]
through that you know
I'll deal with some [ __ ] broad
looking at me being like I know I know
I'm disappointed with this to it no
problem sweetheart
all right same-sex marriage dear bill
I'm in Australia and I work at a country
school a little time ago there was a
vote in this country which endorsed
same-sex marriage on the following day I
was working and my boss asked me to go
retrieve some backdrop and clean up a
local hall where the kids had a school
play the night before so the backdrop
was a big rainbow colored piece of
canvas which was about eight meters long
and it was heavy all right so that's
about 24 feet 25 feet and the only way
to get it to my truck was to drape it
around my shoulders some people like
this guy's really gay and proud also
there was a minor ball there was also a
mirror ball which belonged to the school
which needed to be brought back so I had
that in my hand as I left the hall on
the sidewalk the only two gay guys in my
small county town were walking their
little dog and stopped to say hi so I'm
standing there the day after the game
boat with a mirror ball in my hand and
draped in a rainbow colored scenery when
another man I know who is the biggest
town gossip drove by and his trucks
staring open-mouthed so now mate I have
the reputation of being the third gay
man in the village how can I recover
from this situation tell this story why
don't you just tell the [ __ ] story do
what [ __ ] village do you live in way
like somebody drives by and all of a
sudden everybody in town is going to
know it first of all who gives a [ __ ]
I don't know maybe she just act like you
are gay
God knows [ __ ] there's enough women
who [ __ ] fall for gay guys you might
get some more [ __ ] out of it I have no
[ __ ] idea I wouldn't worry about it I
would find the humor in it because the
only thing is gonna happen is guys are
gonna break your balls about it but
we're not gonna have a problem with it
if anything they're gonna ask you to do
like a makeover right by the time they
realize you're straight you [ __ ] bang
them yeah I wouldn't worry about it all
right but I'm also of a certain age
where I just don't give a [ __ ] what
people think anymore if you're younger
I'm sure you know it's probably
bothering you on some level but I don't
think it's gonna affect your life you'll
be fine all right
snitches get stitches Billy by the way
that sounded like a sketch from a silent
film that you were doing there somehow
you fell into that all right Billy Boy
I'm a little freaked out I live in poor
in a poor American city with its fair
share of crazy desperate violent people
last weekend I was driving onto my block
and I saw a workman struggling to
parallel park they couldn't do it so
they pulled out real fast and smashed
the back of a parked car the Vans sped
away I wrote down the name of the
business that was printed on the work
van I wanted to be a good neighbor so I
left an anonymous note on the smash car
describing what I saw later that day the
guys whose car was smashed went around
looking for who wrote the note it came
back to me he asked me for my
information so that his insurance
company could call me and record my
statement I said okay the next day the
guy said the cops were coming by and
wanted to hear my statement as I was the
only witness I said okay fine now I'm
getting a little nervous about an hour
before the cops come by I find out the
driver of the work man is a
scary-looking [ __ ]
who just moved onto my block no Jesus so
now I'm freaked out because I don't want
him to know I'm the witness I stay in my
house but peer through the curtains and
watched the cops bang on his door and
the scary guy starts yelling at the cops
and denies every
and eyeing everything the guy with
damaged car is yelling at him and it's
ugly the damaged car guy calls me it
wants me to tell the cops what I saw I
sure as hell am NOT walking out my front
door and pulled view of the scary guy so
I agreed to meet the cops in the alley
behind my house because I don't want the
scary guy to know I'm the witness so I'm
talking to the cops in the alley and of
course the scary guy walks past and
looks over at us and points his fingers
finger so now my cover is blown you know
what [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] that guy walking
around [ __ ] yelling at people he's a
[ __ ] I bet he's not even tough
screaming and [ __ ] yelling this is a
good time for you to be young guy go go
take some [ __ ] jujitsu classes or
something like that [ __ ] this guy this
guy's annoying the [ __ ] out of me
walking around pointing his finger at
you yeah go [ __ ] yourself you're a piece
of [ __ ] you hit somebody else's car and
you drove away you [ __ ]
anyways on the plus side he doesn't know
which house I live in or what car I
Drive but I think he would recognize me
if he saw me on the street what where
did I go wrong
do you think this guy is gonna kick my
ass I tried to remain anonymous during
this whole thing but maybe I should have
shouldn't have agreed to tell the cops
anything what would you have done oh I
absolutely would have [ __ ] wrote down
I absolutely would have wrote down I
would done exactly what the [ __ ] you did
I hate when people do that when they hit
your car and they [ __ ] drive away
like that [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy
screaming and yelling IIIi don't know
dude I don't know how to fight but I did
something about bullies I can't [ __ ]
stand him so [ __ ] him I would have done
exactly what you did okay I think you
have a right to be concerned about your
safety but like I mean what does that
tell you about yourself okay this is
this is a problem in your life that you
can easily go solve maybe use this as an
opportunity to learn some self-defense
you know what I mean
and yeah and I don't know this guy just
seems like he just yells at people big
scary guy and he goes around yelling at
people yeah he's not I don't know I
don't know the guy but I'm just saying
[ __ ] him anyways I have no fighting
skills so now I have to sneak in and out
of my house and worry about this [ __ ]
time to move well I mean you might want
to entertain that I don't know I mean it
doesn't sound like it's a nice [ __ ]
neighborhood to begin with if you can
move to a nicer neighborhood maybe you
should do that but you shouldn't be
living in fear either way so if you're
gonna stay there there's plenty of
self-defense courses go out there learn
how to [ __ ] defend yourself all right
don't go looking for a confrontation but
just know if that guy you know it comes
to you you'll be able to handle yourself
but you you shouldn't be going around as
a man [ __ ] live in fear all right
wife hates [ __ ] oh Jesus here's a
way to [ __ ] in the podcast huh my god
hey Billy blue balls
longtime listener of the podcast hoping
for some advice from you and the lovely
Nia well unfortunately my beautiful wife
isn't here right now I've been with my
wife for five years and we've been
married for six months dude you like the
[ __ ] 10th person that's written in
that their wife doesn't like to give
[ __ ] it's just like isn't that
something that should be disclosed
before you get married what if all of a
sudden she found out that you don't like
to hold doors you know or some [ __ ]
you know I don't like to [ __ ] in I don't
like to buy expensive gifts I mean I'm
trying to think of the thing that that
guy could do that is the [ __ ] the
male equivalent to marrying something
that's finding out they don't like to
give a [ __ ] if you're if you don't
like to get a give a [ __ ] you
shouldn't get [ __ ] married gay or
straight you have no business getting
married all right
Jesus Christ I mean if every guy in the
world got a [ __ ] every [ __ ] day I
mean or every couple of days I mean that
the amount of [ __ ] the the level of
friction in the [ __ ] world would just
would go down you can't do it too much
because then we would take it for
granted well tell you you know takes a
lot of the edge off I don't know that's
a--that's a [ __ ] tragedy sir I'm
sorry you're in this situation anyways
he says I've been with my ex I've been
with my wife sorry hoops forty and
slipped there but with my wife for five
years and we've been married for six
months a couple weeks ago we were in the
beginning stage of having sex when she
asked me what I wanted her to do which I
thought was great I replied that I'd
like her to blow me while my dick was in
her hand she told me she hates giving me
[ __ ] my dick immediately went limp
in her hand there was no recovery this
killed my mood so I had the shower and
left to study yeah and I gotta tell you
something that should be like a [ __ ]
major red flag to her you know if I said
to my wife I hate going down on you and
then her [ __ ] dried up right in front
of my [ __ ] face and then she took a
shower and left I'd be like uh-oh
where's she going and who was she
meeting yeah that's a terrible [ __ ]
thing to say and I know this this whole
thing we're just anything a woman says
now is [ __ ] champion but like this
whole [ __ ] thing we're like
everything is about the woman now and
the guy can go [ __ ] himself is complete
[ __ ] this is something that should
have been disclosed and what did she did
she just learned in the last six months
that she doesn't like to give [ __ ]
well dude this is [ __ ] crazy anyways
later I asked her what made her feel
that way but she couldn't really give me
an answer I've been avoiding sex with
her the past couple of weeks because
that's all I can think about when she
wants to have sex we've been about her
saying that she doesn't she hates giving
you [ __ ] we've been together for
five years and this is the first time
I'm hearing about this despite her say
she loves it when I go down on her oh
yeah I mean this is just you know this
is your classic one-way street sir
am I wrong to think that this is selfish
in some way like what has happened to
men that that you're so [ __ ] beaten
down that you actually have to ask me
this this is making me feel sad for you
sir
because am I wrong to think this is
selfish in some way especially since she
loves it when I go down on her how do I
deal with this any advice from you and
Nia would be appreciated come to
Australia and go [ __ ] yourself
well Nina isn't here um Wow I would just
say look I gotta be honest with you I
would tell her how she made you feel
when she said that and
and I would tell you that you you think
it's crazy that she she doesn't I mean I
don't she says she hates to do it does
that mean she's not gonna do it but I
understand I totally understand your
reaction going limp the second a woman
says she's not into it I mean that's
what a normal part a guy does you're not
into this I forget it forget it
then it just gets weird no we can try
something else not forget it forget it
now I get it I repulsed you I'm out of
here I'm already putting on my
windbreaker I'm out the door
Wow how do you navigate these waters
I would just get her to clarify you said
you hate giving me [ __ ] what does
that mean me specifically do you like
giving [ __ ] but not to me or you
just hate giving [ __ ] in general how
long have you felt this way you know
like but you love it when I go down on
you that's what you got to go Columbo
here just keep asking questions so you
don't like to blow me but you like it
when I go down on you and you're okay
with this do you feel that I should be
okay with this this is what you do you
just [ __ ] remember that Guy Fieri
food review it went viral he opened a
restaurant here in Times Square and this
guy wrote this [ __ ] review all of it
was questions is there a reason why the
menu looks like an eye chart are you
aware that the chicken is gray like he
just totally trashed him and he did it
all in questions it was that blue it was
a [ __ ] work of art I think that
that's how you go about this you just
you just ask question after question
yeah
what did you mean when you said that is
it my dick specifically or is it all
dicks how long you felt this way did you
feel that this wasn't something
important to bring up to me before I
married you is this a phase you're going
through do you think you might like to
blow me next week do you have feelings
for women that you've been suppressing
and now you're realizing you know what
do you think about when I go down on you
are you thinking how good it feels you
think about some chick at the office is
there something I need to know before I
put a [ __ ] kid in you and then I'm
really [ __ ] because [ __ ] are
already out the [ __ ] door I don't
need to add alimony and [ __ ] child
support to the goddammit well alimony is
going to be there anyways that's what I
would do I would go Columbo
just I would just do that you know I'm
not the smartest person here but like I
just feel like you know I scratch your
back you scratch my back yes sir that is
[ __ ] terrible and it's completely
unacceptable yeah if you don't like
giving [ __ ] you should not get
married gay or straight you should not
do that or it's a very least you should
[ __ ] tell the person you know it's
like you marry a musician and then you
tell them six months later you hate
music I hate it when you play the guitar
what yeah that you know the whole thing
you've dedicated your life to I [ __ ]
hate that's not the same thing yeah
[ __ ] is an important thing really is
an important thing you know but listen
now I gotta play devil's advocate how
often do you bathe you know are you
showering are you keeping yourself
[ __ ] you know now you trim in the
jungle down there I don't know I don't
know I don't know what you need to
[ __ ] do I don't know but if you were
[ __ ] like not a clean person why the
[ __ ] would she marry you I don't know
dude this is like I be on I think the
whole the whole marriage could unravel
on this thing
I mean what the [ __ ] another question so
where does that put me for the rest of
the marriage when I want a [ __ ]
you know I have to do what I got to go
to a massage parlor
even then I mean yes you don't want your
dick in some [ __ ] hookers mouth with
or without a condom
even then there's always gonna be a
[ __ ] condom it's just like I don't
know pleasing the person you're with is
part of being you know with somebody if
you're not gonna make them feel good
like that I mean that's that's I don't
know I don't know about that one I you
know what I would refer to to a I think
you guys need to go to some sort of
therapy and I don't know I got a I don't
know but some women aren't into that
some of them don't like it they get
grossed out by it there is that but like
which is fine you just tell somebody you
know maybe then you just marry some guy
that just wants to [ __ ] jackhammer
and yeah he's good but that I mean I
don't want to [ __ ] tell you but that
is a hell of a thing six months in Wow
anyway I got to find a [ __ ] bar where
I can go watch this goddamn game is it
Veterans Day or Memorial Day I can never
keep anything [ __ ] I just know both
of those about the troops right I think
this is Memorial Day weekend right is
that what this is I look at that rich
boss sent me a [ __ ] sent me a [ __ ]
text here and more real day Memorial Day
yes this is Memorial Day and then
there's Veterans Day and then there's
Labor Day there's Flag Day when is
Veterans Day I don't know Columbus days
in October I have no idea Jewish [ __ ]
isn't [ __ ] September Jesus [ __ ] is in
December in April
sometimes March what else is in this
Martin Luther King Day George
Washington's birth Presidents Day I
think that's all the days I missed this
day all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and ladies if you don't like giving
[ __ ] you should probably let
somebody know before you get married and
you know to be fair guys same thing you
don't like going downtown then you know
I don't want to tell you you shouldn't
be married to somebody that's it I speak
in absolutes with no research behind it
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on you on Thursday